chinese authorities in shanghai say
residents will have to stay in their
homes until cover 19 has been completely
eradicated from the city
as many as 25 million people have been
confined to their homes since the
beginning of april to contain a spike in
coronavirus cases the strict measures
are part of china's zero coveted
strategy which is being met with growing
anger and frustration the economy is
also feeling the strain the lockdown has
caused chaos at shanghai's port which is
disrupting global supply chains and
pushing up prices
for more on that we're joined here in
our studio by dw correspondent clifford
cooney clifford china's lockdown
measures uh in dealing with covet are
severe what sort of economic
consequences will all this happen
well it's going to have very severe
economic consequences i mean it's truly
a remarkable lockdown a quarter of the
population of china is under some form
of lockdown and it's even more
remarkable when you think that there's
134 thousand coveted deaths in germany
and china has had 4 600 and yet they've
completely shut down the whole economy
uh in in shanghai in particular and and
other major cities in china so it's
hitting real estate it's hitting exports
it's hitting retail um and it's causing
major problems for supply chain we have
shanghai you know
the busiest port in the world and um
what they've done in in a lot of chinese
factories for example
they've created bubbles because the
workers all live in dormitories on site
so sometimes the production has been
fine but you can't get your products out
because the truck drivers are in uh
in quarantine you know so there's all
these sort of things and also in china
for example um you use a chop to uh to a
stamp a government stamp to get business
done but all the government offices are
closed so really the economy is kind of
seizing up and um the economy grew
faster than we were expected in the
first three months but already this
month is signs of that it could be
dropping quite severely
most other countries in the world have
accepted that they are going to have to
learn to live with the coronavirus that
the virus isn't just going to go away
why is po why is china sticking to its
zero covered policy
well i think there's a couple of reasons
i mean one of the reasons is that the
public health services is still
underdeveloped and there is a genuine
worry that if there is a mass infections
that the hospitals won't be able to cope
that there won't be enough beds that
there won't be enough icus and uh to
look after people
but there's also a big political
backdrop to this i mean this is the year
where xi jinping will go for an
unprecedented third term um in the
autumn and uh he needs to make sure that
he's he's put a lot of political capital
into this saying that we're going to get
rid of of kovid and so he's he now has
to back that up and um there's a problem
as well with the vaccinations in china
that the the chinese vaccines don't work
so he has to really as they don't work
as well anyway as western vaccines and
so they're what they're doing is they're
sticking their he has to stick to his
guns um in this one and there's also a
geopolitical aspect where um china has
sort of been touting its success in
combating covets so far with the zero
covert policy as a way of highlighting
the fact that you know in the u.s for
example things weren't handled as well
you had a million deaths um you know so
there's a big geopolitical aspect to it
as well so he really needs to kind of
stick to this zero covert policy if just
for the political capital
save face too china has even created a
museum celebrating its victory over
coveted which well i think that's still
a little ways on yeah clifford thank you
so much clifford coonan from our
business unit
you